a little while back I did a Sadler's
quick takes it's number three that had
to do with prioritization and in that
video I promised that I would do another
quick take about the topic of being
truly well read so this is that quick
take I'm going to make good on that
promise and I'm going to say right off
the bat that nobody is truly well read
because there isn't any sort of
universal consensus Criterion for what
that would look like and not just
universally like across different
disciplines but even in say the field
that I work in and that the person who
was worried about this uh was talking
about namely philosophy I mean look at
this bookshelf behind me I haven't read
every single book in this bookshelf and
you know some of them might be books
that would be good for me but not
necessarily for somebody else there's
inevitably going to be some major gaps
in there and so you know we should think
about this notion of what it means to be
really well read it doesn't have to do
with a bookshelf behind you or some list
that you've put together and say good
reads I've got a good reads and I
haven't updated the things that I've
actually read or started reading for
years and years so people could have all
sorts of mistaken ideas about that what
I want to really address right up front
is not just the concept or pseudo
concept of being well read or we can add
the intensifier truly well read I want
to address the assumptions and the
feelings that go along with this as a
concern
I think that you know one of the
greatest ones or most widespread ones
that I see when people Express these
sorts of interests and concerns and
ideals is that of anxiety they are
concerned that there's something that
they're falling short of they're missing
out on and they're they're not enough
they're not doing enough they haven't
started on the path or process that
would get there get them to some sort of
imagined endpoint where they are
genuinely well read and we could compare
this to other similar worries that
people have you could think about in
terms of financial stability right you
know the Ancients pointed out as part of
you know being moderately well read
knowing that this is a common theme in
ancient philosophy and indeed not just
in philosophy but in you know religious
texts and in literature and and so many
other things that you really never can
have enough wealth if your goal is to
have security through your wealth as a
matter of fact the more wealth you have
the more conscious you become of how
easy it would be to deprive you of it or
for it to rot or for you know some
catastrophe due to Fortune to take it
all away from you right or for your you
to die while you've accumulated like a
miser all these stacks of gold coins or
something like that we could also think
of it in terms of physical
accomplishments you know I'm going to
build this wonderful beautiful body
that's going to be so buff and you know
swole and pick all the you know you're
never going to be enough and it's it's
the same with books right you can keep
on reading and you'll never get to the
end of your library and then you can
walk into another library and be like oh
man look at all these shelves full of
books that I'll never actually get to
and this does uh tend to produce a kind
of
worry a fear and anxiety for many people
an anxiety that has to do with several
different elements one is their own
self-image their own self-understanding
another is whatever it is that they've
got locked away up in their head that
they've managed to accumulate and those
two are connected with each other
another of these is what other people
are telling them because there's so many
you know advice givers out there oh man
you got to read this book you got to
read this book oh if you haven't read
this you don't know anything about
philosophy and most of these people are
just you know flailing around in the
dark themselves and they bought into
somebody else's program or they're
making it up as they go along and many
of them are just full of crap you know
you don't have to believe that and then
we have the physical artifacts which not
only you know exist in libraries and
shelves and books that we can hold in
our hands but all these electronic media
that you can find online you know know a
lot of the ancient literature that we
still have you can find digitized and
available for you and so you know the it
is it does make sense that people would
feel a bit anxious about where they are
and how they understand themselves in
relation to others who at least to them
and to many others are held up as like
Paragons of the well-educated person you
know I'll just use an example right here
so you know somebody who I personally
like and respect quite a bit Alistair
McIntyre wrote this great book after
virtue you know decades into his career
and it's uh very important this is the
third edition
it really did I mean it didn't radically
change virtue ethics or academic
philosophy but it did make a big impact
right and you look at the stuff that
he's talking about in here and you know
if you've read the book you can actually
tell that he he knows some areas way
better uh than others and you know knows
better than me about quite a few things
but there's other things where he got
took he got taken to task by experts you
know for his take on Kierkegaard they
actually
Scholars wrote a whole book uh trying to
rebut him and then he contributed to it
uh Anthony long a great scholar of
Hellenistic uh philosophy wrote about
how McIntyre got stoicism wrong and we
could go on and on and on and on
everybody has got blind spots everybody
even if they've had the opportunity to
study philosophy or other things for
decades and decades and decades there's
more that they haven't read than that
they actually have read and for all of
us every single one of us no matter how
much time we have to devote to studying
philosophy no matter how much we've
accumulated along the way we are more
gaps in an education than a solid
education and anybody who pretends
otherwise is either deluded or they're
selling you some sort of program or they
themselves got you know taught something
and they didn't venture out of its
narrow confines because they you know
they
they thought that was the fullness of
things and that could be forgiven if we
go back like hundreds of years when
there just weren't that many texts
available even if you were a
conscientious and careful reader
belonging to the Republic of letters
that existed in say the 17th and 18th
and even arguably the 19th century we've
had an explosion there are more books
more articles more texts than you could
ever possibly read in a lifetime in
which all you had to do was read and
digest these works so you don't have to
feel as if somehow you have been you
know uniquely missing out and other
people are so much better educated than
you
better educated is a completely relative
term whoever we pick as our ideal to
strive after they they are also very you
know imperfect and if they're honest
people they'll tell you so that they
haven't studied all these things as a
matter of fact McIntyre is a good
example of this in his next book in the
series I'm not going to try to reach for
it because I I would have to go off
camera a little bit who's Justice which
rationality he says you know
I'm going Beyond after virtue in this
and I'm going to talk about this and I'm
going to talk about that and I know that
I also could have talked about this and
that I just didn't get to it or I'm not
competent to do it and then there's all
sorts of other things that I can be at
least conscious that I've I've left out
so you don't have to try to strive after
some sort of illusory ideal of being
truly well read even just being well
read you know you could revise this and
here's my suggestion for those who are
laboring under this this misconception
and who are making themselves feel bad
as a result don't worry so much about
whether you're well read or not
be concerned with making small bits of
progress finding texts that
you can be relatively confident that
you're going to get something out of and
start reading them so you know great
example people are always aware should I
start in philosophy and I always say
Plato's dialogues and they're like oh
well which ones must I read and in what
order and I'm like
you don't have to be so concerned about
that I mean here I I actually do have
some suggestions for which ones would be
best to start out with but you don't
have to read every single one I mean
you're not going to get everything out
of the text the first the second the
tenth time anyway you're going to be
reading and rereading and going back and
forth and maybe stop reading Plato for a
while and you go on to Aristotle or you
jump to Rene Descartes or you you know
read some 20th and 21st century texts
about Plato or pick whatever you want
you can always come back to it and you
may not be particularly ready for one
you know text or author at this point in
time that's okay you got your life ahead
of you you can come back to them if you
read Nietzsche and you're like I I don't
I don't see what everybody says is so
great about this person odds are you've
probably missed something right uh but
the good news is you you can read the
book again you can come back to it five
years later you can do all sorts of
things along those lines and so put the
stress instead on what are you reading
now what are you going to take on
and you know what are you slowly
accumulating for yourself you don't have
to try to read everything you couldn't
possibly do so anyway and you don't have
to worry about comparing yourself with
others who you know are being held up as
Paragons of being well read or even
presenting themselves as being well read
to make you you know feel a little bit
bad most of those people uh are not
particularly well read you know if when
you look at the field of people talking
to each other about philosophy and this
this pertains just as much to academic
philosophy as it does to the popular
world that the internet has opened up
where people jockey for position and you
know kind of posture and uh present
themselves as being you know
being a better reader than they actually
are that happens all the time in
academic philosophy as well
um you you really don't know whether
somebody truly understands a particular
philosopher or text or something like
that unless you've got some background
yourself and you can judge and these are
always probabilistic judgments they're
not perfect deductions or anything like
that and the good news is you don't
actually have to worry about any of that
if you just want to make some progress
for yourself you should measure your
degree of being if you want to use the
term well-read you should measure that
against where you were a year ago or
where you were five years ago or where
you were even just before you read this
latest book that you're probably going
to have to go back and re-read sections
off or maybe the whole thing uh in a
little while or five years from now or
20 years from now and you'll get more
out of it next time around and that that
is perfectly okay so I mean you don't
actually need my permission or my
approval or anything like that in order
to throw away this term well-read or uh
truly well read but if that helps you at
all saying well Dr Sadler said that I
don't have to be so concerned with that
then that's that's cool great I'll give
that to you but you you don't need that
you can you can just go on and read the
text that you're going to do and make an
honest effort at it and over time time I
can promise you if you stick to it
things are going to accumulate and over
the process of reading and re-reading
you never become truly well read or
anything like that but you get to know
the the field that you're in and if you
only know portions of it that's fine
that's still something really good
you're getting exposed to some of the
finest thinkers uh you know available to
us as part of our wonderful Heritage as
human beings and you get to be in this
this long conversation which you don't
have to hear every bit of so that's what
I have to say about that hopefully these
are some encouraging words for people
there's no uh you know intention here of
tearing anything down I just want to
like remove some obstacles primarily
affective ones stemming from assumptions
that people have so that they can live a
better life as readers of philosophy and
of literature more broadly